la collection hivernale 2.0 sera en
magasin et seulement début octobre
plutôt qu'au début septembre d'habitude
vous avez beaucoup plus d'inventaire
dehors contraire dehors et tout est là
ça commence à rentrer à kong ou de sa
rente pour limiter le retard seulement
un mois l'entreprise de montréal doit
payer beaucoup plus cher pour animer ces
produits d'asie ça nous coûte à peu près
3 millions $ de plus cette année
seulement en shopping de surplus 3
millions c'est beaucoup d'argent c'est
pas justifié c'est de l'extorsion jours
certains avec des soubresauts mais la
crise des comptages m'attendais pas
vraiment transporter un conteneur de la
chine vers l'amérique du nord coûté
environ trois mille dollars américains
avant la pandémie le prix avait déjà
doublé l'automne dernier à 6000 $ et il
a encore quadruples et depuis pour
atteindre maintenant 25 mille dollars
américains parfois même plus avec le
pendu mais bon se retrouver avec des
entreprises fermées qui pouvaient pas
déballer les conteneurs donc les
contenus stockés dans leur cour d'autres
dans des centres de distribution
d'autres encore ont été coincés dans des
spas ou un bon là m'est d'avis et un
problème
à la pandémie s'est ajoutée la fermeture
du canal de suez pendant une semaine en
mars et les feux de forêt sur la côte
ouest ça c'est la recette parfaite
augmentation de la demande diminution de
capacité alors les prix se sont mis à
augmenter et pas pas des germes heures
dans cette course pour transporter la
marchandise les firmes d'intermédiaires
doivent utiliser tous leurs contacts
juste pour trouver et faire partir du
conteneur c'est pas négociable c'est
c'est vraiment un exemple pour de la loi
de l'offre et la demande il ya tellement
de demandes que les compagnies de lignes
maritimes ont le choix qui embarquent et
qu'ils n'embarquent pas les 10
principaux transporteurs maritimes
contrôle 85 % du volume mondial si tu
payes plus de beaucoup plus de chances
de bouger si tu veux y aller avec le
taux régulier sans les additions de
malheureusement c'est dommage mais
malheureusement le composent bougent pas
dans le meilleur des cas les délais de
livraison sont deux à trois fois plus
long qu'à l'habitude l'impact à court
terme c'est des pénuries de stock
à moyen terme génie coûts qui augmentent
dit qu'on va devoir absorber donc on
doit s'attendre à une augmentation du
prix des biens pour sa part point zéro
va augmenter le prix de tous ses
produits de 10% cet automne au lieu de
10 heures 30 % pour vraiment réfléter
coup
aujourd'hui l'entreprise absorbe plus de
la moitié des coûts supplémentaires en
espérant qu'il diminue assez rapidement
on préfère prendre la pilule est resté
sur le marché compétitif et bien et se
reprendre avec les années gentiment
c'est la meilleure façon
absolument je pense la demande va aller
en flèche
parce qu'il ya un manque parce que pas
tout le monde peut se permettre deux
pays d'avancer de l'argent pour le
transport les experts s'attendent à ce
que la pénurie de conteneurs dure au
moins jusqu'en janvier prochain ici
marie claude morin radio-canada mourir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit